♪ ♪
>> Hannity: MORE SHOCKING
VIOLENT CRIME CAUGHT EARLIER
THIS MONTH A POLICE OFFICER IN
ILLINOIS WAS AMBUSHED BY A MAN
WITH AN AX NOW THE OFFICER MADE
A VERY SPLIT DECISION TO SHOOT
AND KILL THE MAN LIKELY SAVING
HIS OWN LIFE TAKE A LOOK.
>> HIGH.
WHO ARE YOU DUDE?
>> TOOK A BREATH DUDE YOU CAME
AT ME WITH A HATCHET.
>> Hannity: JUST THE LATEST
EXAMPLE OF DIFFICULT DATER'S
DECISION THAT POLICE OFFICERS
MUST MAKE ON A DAILY BASIS
UNFORTUNATELY ANTI-POLICE
RHETORIC DEFENDANT THE MANTLE IS
FIELDING MORE AND MORE VIOLENT
CRIME ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR
EXAMPLE FIVE MAJOR CITIES ALL
RUN BY DEMOCRATS ARE NOW ON PACE
TO PASS LAST YEAR'S HIGH
HOMICIDE NUMBERS IN D.C.
THERE'VE BEEN OVER 90 HOMICIDE
SO FAR THIS YEAR BY THE WAY ASK
YOURSELF DO YOU KNOW THE NAMES
OF ANY OF THEM?
INCLUDING A TEENAGER WHO WAS
KILLED OVER THE WEEKEND AN EVENT
CALLED MOCHE ELLA BUT SADLY THE
SENSELESS VIOLENCE IS ALL TOO
COMMON.
IN HARLEM SHOOTING ON
FATHER'S DAY WEEKEND IN THE CITY
OF CHICAGO.
THEY SET THE RECORD AGAIN, 47
SHOT OVER THIS PAST WEEKEND THAT
INCLUDED AN 11-YEAR-OLD GIRL
SHOT IN THE LEG.
GET THIS, LOOK AT THE SCREEN
POLICE ARE NOW SEARCHING FOR A
SUSPECT AFTER NEW FOOTAGE SHOWS
LOUISVILLE MAYOR BEING SUCKER
PUNCHED DURING AN EVENT ON
SATURDAY WHERE THE BIG-CITY
DEMOCRATS TAKE CARE OF SO MUCH
GUN VIOLENCE WAS JOE BIDEN GET A
VISIT CHICAGO BECAUSE HE PAID NO
ATTENTION TO EIGHT YEARS AS
VICE PRESIDENT WHAT WILL HE
DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY THIS
DEMOCRATIC RUN CITY IN THIS DEEP
BLUE DEMOCRATIC STATE FOR THIS
HAVE BEEN GOING ON SINCE HE
FIRST BECAME VICE PRESIDENT.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING WEEKEND
AFTER WEEKEND AFTER WEEKEND NO
SOLUTIONS, NO ATTENTION WE HAVE
SCROLLED THE NAMES OF OUR
AMERICAN TREASURE LOST TO THE
LAWLESSNESS IN MAJOR CITIES.
A WISE DEMOCRATS CONTINUING TO
POLITICIZE THE ISSUE RATHER THAN
WORK TO FIX THE PROBLEM?
WHY IS IT ONLY HEAR ABOUT THE
NAMES OF PEOPLE WITH DEMOCRATS
CAN POLITICIZE THE ISSUE BLAME
REPUBLICANS OR BLAME
DONALD TRUMP.
I'LL ASK AGAIN.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE 575
RIOTS DURING THE SUMMER OF 2020.
THEY HAD DOZENS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, THOUSANDS OF INJURED
COPS, BILLIONS OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE.
REMEMBER WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID
THEY HAVE BECOME THE ENEMY AND
THE CRIME WERE NOW SEEING IN
MAJOR CITIES IS A NATURA